les alpinistes vous diront tous que la
montagne plus forte que qu'il faut la
respecter et essayer de l'amadouer tenté
de la conquérir
mais qu'à la fin les éléments quand ils
se déchaînent ne pardonne pas ou n'est
pas 12 personnes ont été tuées dans une
avalanche dans trois québécoises une dé
québec et de montréal un groupe de
randonneurs étaient partis en excursion
sur les annapurna une destination très
populaire auprès des trekkeurs des
randonneurs pour parler de ces
excursions je reçois l'explorateur
bernard voyer qui était au népal il ya
moins d'un an - monsieur voyez bon choix
soit besoin d'avoir une différence entre
trekkeurs et alpiniste qu'est ce que
c'est
l'alpiniste celui qui veut conquérir le
sommet l'alpiniste et met le pied sur le
glacier
il utilise des corps piolets crampons
l'engagement est beaucoup plus grave
dans les verts rien sur à la randonnée
mais les crevasses là les zones
d'avalanche le manque d'oxygène
le froid extrême le tracas le randonneur
lui c'est un sentier qui contournent ces
massifs de montagne qui donne la
possibilité à beaucoup de gens d'aller
voir ces belles montagnes mais d'abord
et d'en bas le sentier peut culminer
points à 3000 4000 m
mais les sommets en font plus de 8000
les randonneurs ils sont pour alou népal
c'est la plus belle destination de
randonnée au mont les sources d'un
millier à le faire à cette période ci de
l'année
cette période si en fait on pourrait
dire que ruth 200000 très cas de
randonnée parents qui vont dans les
trois principales destinations se
rendent au camp de base de l'everest ou
faire le tour des annapurna ce qui
concerne la tragédie actuelle où le tour
du mana sur une autre montagne de 8000
mètres il peut y en avoir des dizaines
de milliers la répartie sur sont sentis
et ce qu'il faut comprendre ce n'est pas
abandonnée que deux journées parce que
quelquefois on pourrait aisément
pourquoi s'ils ont su que le mauvais
temps santenay pourquoi elles sont
engagées
alors on s'engage plusieurs jours c'est
étrange et elles sont discrets
jours de trek et de randonnée c'est
étrange ou en duo jour ou 8 ans vous
annonce du mauvais temps c'est
aujourd'hui tu vous serez pas êtes loin
de l'arrivée de la sortie je vous écoute
et à cet après midi vous sembliez un peu
surpris de ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui c'est à dire ces conditions
météo extrêmement dur pourquoi à cette
période ci de l'année cela vous surprend
t as c'est la meilleure période
prolongée pâle octobre c'est en temps
normal à des altitudes de 3000 3500
mètres à midi vous pouvez marcher en t
shirt c'est beau les randonneurs ne
porte pas de gros sacs c'est la plus
belle des périodes mais là là c'est
satan pas être qui est arrivé au nord de
au nord de l'est depuis qui a glissé
si oui ces sommets c'est au sommet ont
cette capacité de retenir les masses
nuageuses de fortes chutes de neige
exceptionnelles non comme non prévisible
on peut pas et on me on peut pas prévoir
non ne peut pas prévoir
il n'y a aucune responsabilité auprès
des agences qui des centaines d'agents
pour me pas un millier d'agents dans le
monde qui vante ses voyages là alors ce
genre de randonnée est très démocratique
finalement parce que les gens
relativement en forme peuvent les faire
est ce que c'est bien encadré
parce qu'on va se poser des questions
sur l'encadrement des sherpas des jean
rémy est très régulier très très bien
sont très habitués d'abord ou népal et
les agences mais mission nous d'être
très bonne agence c'est bien encadré
dans la grande majorité des cas sont
très bien encadrés et il n'y a aucune
difficulté technique c'est de la
randonnée on ne nous battons marche en
sac à dos parce que des porteurs et des
ja xv et ses boeufs u mal l'eia qui
portent tous les bagages on a une gourde
d'eau un appareil photo une tuque le
temps devient plus frais et on marche
dans des sentiers quelquefois un peu
rocailleuse des fois on peut pas en
tuant pas des passerelles mais jamais au
met les mains sur le rocher pour ne pas
grimper il n'y a pas de d'endroits
quelquefois effectivement c'est un peu
vertigineux mais rien de plus le danger
il ya des éléments
y at il des enfants on peut s'abriter où
on peut se réfugier en cas de nuit par
se payer des villages toulon c'est
habité d'accord sauf sauf sur les
passages où on
cet au delà de 4000 miles mais des
villages et oui on peut s'arrêter il ya
des traits se font ou les gens ne
dorment que dans des petites auberges et
plus on va en altitude plus elles
deviennent rustique c'est au moins on
comprend que le népal de pays d'abord
très pauvre
d'ailleurs ça me désole le seul gain la
seule entrée d'argent du népal entre la
principale c'est tourisme une tragédie
comme ça m'est donc on peut se mettre à
l'abri mais on ne peut pas prévoir
il ya eu aucune imprudence de la part de
rendre à vous et moi si on nous invite à
leeuw népal en automne prochain faut y
aller il faut y aller c'est la plus
belle des périodes vous vous disiez que
ça vous désole vous êtes vous craignez
contrecoup pour le tourisme au népal où
ça peut ça peut arriver mais
l'engouement les montagnes reste très
très belle merveilleuse et elles ont ce
pouvoir d'attirer le simple aventurier
et ils sont nombreux et ils sont
nombreux à y aller c'est quelquefois un
projet de famille devraient anniversaire
je fête mes 50 ans du vent famille ou un
projet d'école des finances et c'est
trés populace est en forme et marcheurs
montant qui est très accessible
ce n'est pas l'ascension de sommets
c'est autre chose c'est sur ce message
d'espoir qu'on se laisse bercer de comme
souvent on croise les doigts
merci